[Musique]
réellement une partie de la population
des jeunes sont discriminés par les
politiques publiques qui ne s'occupent
pas véritablement de le rsa en est un
des exemples est justement c'est pour
cela qu'il faut pouvoir donner le droit
de vote aux plus jeunes aux élections
municipales dans un premier temps mais
aussi potentiellement aux élections
nationales pourquoi
et bien parce que un élu va d'abord
regarder comment il peut être réélu ou
comment il peut satisfaire son électorat
répondre à son programme politique
et quand vous avez un électorat dont
l'âge médian c'est aujourd'hui le cas
l'âge médian des personnes inscrites sur
les listes électorales ses 50 ans
l'âge médian des personnes qui vont
voter aux élections puisque on sait que
les jeunes vont très peu voté l'âge
médian des personnes qui vont voter aux
élections c'est 60 ans c'est à dire que
si vous prenez l'ensemble des personnes
qui ont voté et qui ont plus de 60 ans
plus une voix vous faites 51% et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut rééquilibrer si on
veut avoir des politiques pour la
jeunesse il faut rééquilibrer le corps
électoral vers la jeunesse
le sujet qui concerne les jeunes de cet
âge là c'est on le fait de voir
d'essayer des skis c'est ce que sera
leur ancrage dans la vie
les choix professionnels et puis ce sont
les amours bon c'est sûr les deux sujets
qui le captive avec comme cadre global
de tout cela l'horizon de la famille
dont les municipales ne sont pas du tout
un sujet qui concerne un jeune de cet
âge là et je dirais le fait même
d'envisager de l'association là est une
démarche que je trouve complètement
factice
finalement on voit pas très bien la
raison sinon de l'espèce de démarches
comme si on voulait flatter un petit peu
les jeunes en leur disant tu vois on
apprend qu'il va intéresser à ce qui se
passe autour de toi mais le jeune je
dirais il a surtout besoin qu'on l'aide
à grandir et je trouve que les
politiques plutôt que de s'intéresser à
ce type de démarche tout à fait tout à
fait factice
devrait vous tous intérêt à s'intéresser
aux problèmes des jeunes pour seulement
précisément s'ancrer dans la vie dans la
vie sociale
si on rajoute des électeurs jeunes
effectivement un million et demi de
personnes et que ont fait en sorte par
ce vote à 16 ans mais aussi par un
certain nombre d'actions comme des
conseils municipaux des jeunes ou autres
de faire que ces jeunes sont non
seulement inscrit mais vont voter alors
là on peut changer la donne parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une abstention
énorme des jeunes et on sait que un
jeune qui ne votent pas quand il a 18 ou
19 ans on va être plutôt dans
l'abstention
alors qu'un jeune qui votent dès sa
majorité électorale va lui être plutôt
un électeur régulier cris faut faire en
sorte moi je crois par exemple avec des
dispositifs comme le service national
universel de fer que ces jeunes qui ont
autour de 16 17 ans on leur rappelle les
valeurs de la république
on leur rappelle et on les fait voter on
les amène vers les urnes pour avoir
ensuite des citoyens qui continuent à
participer à la vie de la nation
pendant la durée de l'offre ce n'est pas
ce dont ils ont besoin
ils ne sont pas prêts à saisir un
instrument dont ils ne sentent nothomb
dont ils ne perçoivent pas le type
d'intérêt le type de projection dans la
vie sociale ils ne perçoivent pas
l'utilité de cela et il ne se
désintéresse pas de la politique mais la
voix de très loin et et ce n'est pas dur
ce n'est pas leur horizon
donc les mesures que propose monsieur
chauvet sont factices parce que les
jeunes
excusez moi les jeunes des banlieues
c'est pas en proposant le jeu le vote à
16 ans là je pense que vous allez faire
surprendre vos électeurs si vous allez
leur raconter ça les gens des banlieues
on sait très bien qu'ils sont pris par
des problèmes très graves très sérieux
donc il faut absolument que nous nous
occupions mais qui sont d'abord et avant
tout le fait l'absence d'un ancrage
solide dans une vie familiale
or ce que je compte quand je constate
que je conteste c'est la façon dont les
lois de sur la famille depuis une
dizaine d'années on
totalement chamboulé les repères de la
vie familiale moi je crois que ce débat
est pas du tout factice mais qu'il est
au contraire fondamentale pourquoi
arrive-t-il maintenant et pourquoi est
il porté par mon collègue modem david
corceiro c'est parce que nous avons
aujourd'hui une crise de la démocratie
fondamentalement une crise de la
représentation les électeurs ne se
sentent pas représentés vers les
extrêmes ils vont vers d'autres formes
de participation et nous nous avons
proposé non seulement effectivement le
droit de vote des jeunes mais aussi la
proportionnelle mais aussi le vote à
distance le vote par internet le vote
par anticipation la facilité de recourir
aux procurations pour moderniser notre
démocratie française qui est aujourd'hui
archaïque et profondément en décalage
avec la société
ce qu'il faut absolument c'est que la
politique se concentrent sur l'avenir
des jeunes ça c'est tout à fait
essentiel avec des aides qui sont à la
fois j'irai réel moi j'ai cité la
situation des jeunes qui sont par
exemple en grande difficulté familiale
et qui ont besoin 6-2 d'appui mais
qu'ils soient des appuis financiers mais
qui sont aussi des appuis relationnel je
dirais est tout à fait au delà de ce qui
est proposé actuellement parce que on
sait qu'on peut vaguement les
accompagner de 18 à 21 ans et encore
c'est de plus en plus vague l'aide
sociale à l'enfance ase de plus près ce
fut tout et par rapport à ça mais vatea
non cela ne suffit pas à établir le tir
et la situation d'un jeune et puis il ya
des aides symbolique qui sont le
renforcement des liens familiaux
c'est cela qui est essentiel pour les
jeunes beaucoup plus que de l'ailé
droite vote dont il ne quitte à
l'instrument qu'il ne leur parle pas
[Musique]